تعمل تاهيل لنفسها لانها قبل كده لما رجعت
في خيانه عهد المسلسل لم تكن في الحاله
الابداعيه او اللياقه الابداعيه هي ستعود
للتمثيل حتما يعني ده كله تمهيد للعوده
وستجد شركات انتاج تطلب منها ان تمثل ايضا
على واثق من ده لان الحلقه ممثله موهوبه
ولها ايضا جمهور وجاذبيه والحاله اللي هي
فيها حتى وهي بعيده عن التمثيل جعلت
الجمهور يعني يترقبها لكن نصيحه مني يجب
ان تتاهل اولا حتى تقف مجددا امام
الكاميرا طب الى من الصعب على الممثل او
اي نجم يكون مشهور وعنده جمهور يحبوا
اعمال ناجحه ان يتاثر حياته الخاصه سيد
مؤكد انه ساعات الجمهور وهو متباين في
جمهور بيحكم على الفنان بيصلي او بيصوم او
بيحج وفي جمهور اخر بيحكم عليه على الشاشه
فيجب ان نهايه تتوقع ان اللي بيحكم على
الفنان اخلاقيا او بيعتقد انه مظاهر
الصلاه والصوم والحج وكل الطقوس دي جزء
مهم جدا في حب الفنان او عدم حبه هتخسر
القطاع ده لكن في قطاع بيحكم على الشاشه
فقط اكيد المتابعات على السوشيال ميديا
تباينت فيها الاراء هناك من يرفض خلعها
للحجاب وهناك من يراها انها حريه شخصيه